this energy is real but even in our
lowest moments it's the other people
around you it's your family that builds
you up so thank you nick cannon thanks
his fans for their support following the
tragic death of his five-month-old son
thank you thank you that's all i can
say we're gonna get through it you guys
are making me feel better on wednesday's
episode of the nick cannon show the 41
year old reflected on the love he's been
shown in the wake of his youngest son
zen's death the newborn whom nick shared
with model alyssa scott died of brain
cancer and a subsequent tumor people
keep asking me how i'm doing i say i'm
vertical i'm standing and asking you
know that's a good start
um
yesterday dr berman our therapist she
she said uh a lot of people say take it
one day at a time but that's too long
gotta take it five minutes at a time
in this five minutes right now i feel
good nick also opened up about his
decision to return to work so quickly to
me this isn't work you know what i mean
this is this is love
and this is
and i love you back
but this this is therapy for me this is
therapeutic but before nick went live on
tv he went live on instagram and thanked
the audience for their energy before
saying a prayer
thank you for waking us up this morning
thank you for this opportunity father
says thank you for being the deliverer
of the fortress
as for how he's doing during the show
the triple threat admitted it's a
process
grieving and how it is like it's like
the ocean it's like an ebb and flow like
every five minutes you never know
yesterday was
it was a little easier than today
because yesterday i was so
laser focused and then even numb
you know what i mean so so i was just i
knew i just had to get it done
today i'm a little i'm i'm a little torn
i'm a little confused nick who first
revealed his son died on his show
tuesday added that he had previously
kept zen's diagnosis private out of
respect to alyssa and while he admitted
that he's quote not fine he told his
audience that their support was helping
him feel better the onslaught of of
really love you know and care and you
got that but it's brand new to me so i'm
dealing with it so
so thank you now a rep for nick show
tells et that the host will continue
doing live shows through the end of next
week and the program will go on a
previously scheduled hiatus starting
december 20th until the new year
on tuesday's show nick praised alyssa
for showing strength amid a tragedy
alyssa was just a mate like the
strongest woman i've ever seen was
emotional when she she needed to be but
was always the best mom and continues to
be the best mom possible and on
wednesday a source told et now nick just
wants to be there for alyssa quote he
wants nothing more than to honor the
time he had with zen and to focus on
being there for alyssa he also shared a
picture he took of alyssa and zen on the
beach sunday before he died the strength
that this woman possesses in this moment
and
i
i apologize for so many things i'm not
going to get everything right this
process is difficult for the both of us
but i just thank you for being that
strength and being that rock uh love to
alyssa love to her extended family
mothers are superheroes um
at every aspect
and i i want to just take this time out
to say um
she is doing well but continue to pray
for continue to pray for our entire
family